[Music]
alright it's 9 a.m. here in Singapore
and it is 9 p.m. in our nation's capital
and in less than 24 hours the DOJ is
watchdog is scheduled now to release
this all-important IG report 18 months
we've all been waiting and as we speak
we have a team of experts lined up they
will be analyzing the 500 plus pages in
this report line by line and we will
break it all down I promise as soon as
we get it and also tonight withstanding
pressure from rod Rosenstein and other
obstructionist bureaucrats in the DOJ
this impending report should shed a
critical light on what were the crimes
of Hillary Clinton and how the FBI the
DOJ high-ranking members of the Obama
administration completely and
intentionally fixed botched this
criminal investigation and of course the
contents of this report could be totally
ruined by rod Rosenstein and his
bureaucratic friends at the Department
of Justice remember this report could be
very embarrassing for all of them so
tonight we're asking the questions will
this report include massive redactions
was the report altered by the upper
echelon of the DOJ where Michael
Horowitz his findings twisted and parsed
or altered in any way we're gonna have a
full report tomorrow you don't want to
miss of course the facts they're not
even in dispute look at the side of your
screen
Hillary Clinton we know fact it is
irrefutable violated 18 USC 793 the
Espionage Act
she mishandled she destroyed classified
top-secret special access programming
information it's a fact she deleted
33,000 subpoenaed emails 18 USC 20 71
that's a fact
she acid washed her hard drive with
bleach pit and that's a fact - and she
destroyed literally had aides destroyed
her mobile devices with a hammer that's
a fact and of course remember Christiane
saucier he spent a year in prison for
six pictures of on his cell phone of the
submarine he was proud to work on far
less severe than anything Hillary Rodham
Clinton did that too was a fact and we
also know that call me and trumpeter
Peter struck they started writing the
exoneree
of Hillary in early May of 2016 but they
didn't interview her and 17 other
witnesses until early July then three
days later Oh magically they exonerated
her and we know they pulled out the
legal definition of gross negligence and
they pulled out the Foreign Intelligence
EES likely hacked into that server in
that bathroom closet that is a fact now
we have a very important developing
story we got to tell you about tonight
and that is the deputy AG there you see
on your screen that we just mentioned
rod Rosenstein now according to
reporting from our very own catherine
herridge the deputy AG of the united
states of america actually threatened to
subpoena the emails and other records of
several Republican members of Congress
and their staffs and of course after
losing his temper which according to
multiple sources I know he frequently
does he launched into what was described
as a personal attack against the
congressional staffer now this all came
after the house Intel committee ramped
up its oversight efforts surrounding
multiple DOJ led investigations back in
January in other words let me make this
clear rod Rosenstein was trying to bully
intimidate threaten House Republican
House Intel committee chairmen and their
their members from following and doing
their constitutional duty of oversight
we have in the system and in our country
checks and balances separation of powers
it's actually called the US Constitution
and by the way you should and I will
call it reprehensible that anybody in
the Department of Justice would ever use
their power or threaten to use their
power as in this case America's de-facto
top law enforcement official to
literally intimidate members of Congress
to prevent them from doing their job now
former Chief Assistant US Attorney
Andrew McCarthy he summed it up this way
caught the whole essence of this rod
Rosenstein subpoena threat he's
conflicted and he's acting like it and
meanwhile Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz he's also rightly speaking
out what's this
but this is a classic dispute between
separation of powers the legislature has
the power obviously to oversee and
investigate the executive branch and a
member of the executive branch which is
what red roses sign is shouldn't be able
to bully the legislative branch he
should be transparent he should turn
over the documents he should be
cooperative and in Congress should be
cooperative the executive branch
professor Dershowitz is a thousand
percent right listen to legal expert
attorney Jonathan Turley professor
he's also slamming rod Rosen Stein take
a look I think the threat even one for a
civil subpoena was really reckless he
shouldn't have done it he is subject to
the oversight of the House and Senate
committees these committees have a
history of rather poor oversight this is
for those of us who have argued for
years that these committees need to
exercise real oversight demand documents
and not back down this is actually a
refreshing trend the allegation that one
party used the FBI to investigate the
opposing party is one of the most
serious matters for oversight in our
system it goes to the very heart of our
electoral system and our governmental
system so there's every reason for the
members to want to see these documents
and now some members of Congress they're
also firing back congressman Gowdy and
Meadows just revealed the resolution
roll calling out rod Rosenstein for his
threats to subpoena now of course this
all comes in the shadow of the rampant
obstruction of justice that we know has
been going on with the DOJ not willing
to hand over documents including
specific requests from the house Intel
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez over
documents surrounding the FBI's use of
informants in the Trump campaign a
newness set a deadline for yesterday and
the DOJ completely ignored that deadline
that is really problematic rod Rosen
Stein I have a question what are you
hiding why are you obstructing why are
you intimidating threatening harassing
congressional members and their staffs
now it's time for rod Rosenstein to step
aside or be fired in this case because
if this is an attempt of obstruction of
justice mr. Rosen Stein why won't you
let Congress do their job according to
new political poll numbers look at this
Muller's pop of public image rod Rosen
Stein appointed Mahler is that an
all-time low people are beginning to
understand the AP now reporting that
Muller's team is quote worried that
russian intelligence services will use a
criminal case in Washington to gather
information about its investigation and
u.s. intelligence gathering methods
we're going to have a lot more on that
they never should have filed those
indictments and tonight by the way I
hope you can stomach this your
mainstream corrupt media the destroyed
Trump media has now reached a new low
and as you know despite so much success
at home and the economy and abroad not
including this week here in Singapore
well the president has been
overwhelmingly portrayed negatively in
the press earlier today the president
while he's fighting back he tweeted out
quote so funny to watch the fake news
especially NBC fake news CNN they're
fighting hard to downplay the deal with
North Korea 500 days ago they would have
begged for this deal look like war would
break out our country's biggest enemy
well it's the fake news so easily
promulgated by fools now the president
is right and here's has all the proof
you'll ever need you can't make this up
they call themselves news people it's
pathetic a bunch of lazy overpaid
so-called colleagues and they have a
radical left-wing agenda it's obvious
take a look
usually when Trump signs an agreement
with a foreigner it's a prenup very
almost caveman like it really is
he's like Fred Flintstone running the
country writing things on a stone
actually not even able to do that
President Trump said Kim jong-un is
absolutely invited to the White House so
he said yeah
unless of course Kim jong-un wins the
Super Bowl or the NBA championship why
the praises I can seek a hey we got
along okay we all talk about political
community case like that it went
constructive talks near the language
he's coming out to kiss but that said
range it it's outrageous the way he
talks this guy's a killer a lot of the
reason why we were on the brink of
nuclear war last year I mean part of it
to be sure was because of the North
Korean nuclear test and their missile
test but also because of the reckless
and irresponsible rhetoric from Donald
Trump ratcheting up the tensions and so
now this is kind of the arsonist getting
credit for putting out the fire to
believe that Kim jong-un is gonna give
away his nuclear aren't arsenal which
really gives him the power I think we
went too far and I perhaps nothing evil
idiot just because something hasn't
happened before doesn't mean its
historic that's one thing I think when
you call something historic it means
that it has a good chance of having
lasting implications and I think it's
very unclear at least to my layman's eye
that this does that any previous
president could have easily had a summit
with any previous leader of North Korea
because they've all been very eager to
be legitimated by the President of the
United States and Donald Trump is the
first one to agree to do that
meanwhile over there at MSNBC the
conspiracy theorist choice in cable news
you got liberal morning host Joe Amica
Joe Scarborough thrashing Republicans
who support the Republican
commander-in-chief shocking take a look
owners in the Republican Party had
devolved into a promised call Wade say
it's it's clear that conservatism
liberalism voting records none of those
things matter it is a cult personality
and the president has an extraordinary
hold over his base and pulse and Isaac
one good description for yellow the only
cult are the people that watch that
ridiculous Morning Show of yours now is
see it doesn't matter what President
Trump does it doesn't matter how
successful his agenda becomes or
how much the quality of life for you the
American people forgotten men and women
becomes the media in this country is
blinded by pathological hatred of this
president so much so that it is now out
weighing their desire even for a robust
economy and even peace in the world this
is sick now the press is actively
clearly rooting for this president to
fail if he fails the country fails the
world fails at all costs even if it
means a better quality of life